on va parler donc d'abord des prix
truqués puisque le figaro.fr a publié le
10 janvier un article qui est belle les
arnaques à éviter pendant les soldes
on vous a préparé un petit récap et on
en parle juste après qui fait les soldes
ici ah oui oui oui eh bah refaites les
c'est un scandale découvert par l'ufc
que choisir qui pourrait bien vous
coûter cher en pleine soldes d'hiver
l'organisme a mis le doigt sur un
système frauduleux de grande envergure
de nombreux commerçants trafic et les
prix de leurs produits pour créer de
fausses réductions et vendre leurs
articles soi-disant soldé au prix normal
comment en gonflant simplement le prix
baril sur l'étiquette et ne croyait pas
que les grandes enseignes sont d'épargné
nombreuses d'entre elles sont concernées
un procédé strictement interdit par la
loi alors selon vous les soldes sont
elles vraiment une bonne affaire
alors c'est vrai que les soldes on a vu
plein d' arnaque
voilà sur les soldes vous oui alors je
peux raconter c'est que quand j'étais
très jeune j'ai pour payer les études
j'étais vendeur dans une boutique et
effectivement on le faisait coach ou
fusil alors dit eh bien on vend désert
quand on truquer l'étiquette en gonfler
le prix de départ et ont barré de rouge
on le faisait tous les matins avant
l'ouverture et on mettait un fois
imprimé donc et parce que quéval en
aurait elle pris je suis pareil vos
salaires je mets un prix de départ
sitôt la fin de l'année tous devraient
disparaître je dis pas que c'est une
généralité mais nous nous l'avons fait à
très vite sur non j'ai dit que pour les
seuls il faut savoir bien ciblées et
bien visé devra faire ses soldes un peu
n'importe où comme en amour
non mais c'est vrai trois mois avant
deux mois avant tu cible et puis voilà
tu ça se désole c'est un peu un rituel
pour les gens sont calmes et toute
l'année c'est le seul quand il est en
soldes ce que ça saute en soit le mec
est un seul métal et c'est les soldes
si tu prends des magasins les magasins
de luxe évidemment ça fait des gros
rabais quand tu as un truc à 200 il peut
passer à 50
les gens sont contents mais si tu fais
gifi gemo babou primark à les t shirt à
3 euros toute l'année et dit catherine
et -70%
toute l'année je sais merci à toutes les
beautés moinet